hello my name is harrison lee i'm a
professional competitive yoyoer and
three-time canadian national yo-yo
champion
today i've been challenged to
demonstrate yo-yo tricks and 26 levels
of increasing complexity
today we'll be focusing on yoyo tricks
using an unresponsive yoyo that means
we'll not be going into tricks that use
multiple yoyos
or yoyos that go off the string this is
an endless journey into yoyoing yoyo
tricks continuously evolve and transform
it's very similar to
a hip hop dance where dancers will start
with some fundamentals and then build up
into their own combinations
this is my interpretation of the
challenge complexity is defined
as additional movements additional
elements that are combined in these
tricks and layers in precision control
required so there are two main different
categories of yoyoing there are
responsive yoyos and unresponsive yoyos
for the first few levels we are going to
start with
a responsive yoyo level 1 downward
sleeper
so the downward sleeper is the first
trick that everybody learns when they
start to yoyo
its a simplest trick and involves
throwing the yoyo down letting it spin
for a bit at the very end or sleep
and then bringing it back up so to begin
this trick you start with your arm
faced out and a muscle formation and
then you extend your arm and then flick
your wrist at the very end
the flick of the wrist at the very end
is super super important
because that's what allows it to give
the yoyo the most spin
so it's very similar to you know tennis
or badminton where at the very end when
you
hit and flick your wrist that's where
you get the most power if you don't do
that the yoyo doesn't have enough spin
and unfortunately you'll spin out and
die at the end
and you're sad moving into the next
level will be building off of the
downward sleeper
and adding an additional element that
will propel the yoyo forward
level two walk the dog super common
trick it's the first trick that people
will ask you to do
when they know that you can yo-yo walk
the dog begins by throwing the yoyo down
in a downward sleeper
you then rest the yoyo on the floor
forcing it to propel
forward or you walk the dog and then at
the very end you give it a little tug
and the yoyo returns to you when you are
trying to walk the dog for the first
time
sometimes you might not have enough spin
on the yoyo so when it hits the floor
the yoyo will immediately stop spinning
because of the additional amount of
friction so a lot of professional
yoyoers will avoid this trick
simply because how expensive these yoyos
can cost
and so when somebody asks you to do walk
the dock with your 500
titanium yoyo yoyoers cringe for a bit
and think
uh do i really want to damage the weight
distribution of my yoyo and
mess it all up going into the next level
we're going to be adding a few
additional elements
to make the tricks a lot more showy
level three
around the world around the world
starts in a forward pass and then
instead of it returning to you the yoyo
returning to you
you do a full rotation or you let the
yoyo move around the world
and you rotate the yoyo with your hand
almost like you are swinging it in a
spiral motion
and then you return the yoyo back to
your hand when you're doing around the
world it's important that you follow
through with your revolution
if you don't you have the chance of
hitting yourself in the head
we're going to be introducing a mount to
the next level which will increase the
complexity
and the number of moving parts going on
level 4
rock the baby so rock the baby like the
name suggests
it involves creating a cradle mount and
then rocking the yoyo back multiple
times
generally a solid rock the baby involves
three full swings
and then you drop the yoyo or you drop
the baby out of the mount
and then you bring the yoyo back up it
is important that you stop between
rocks so that you are not moving the
yoyo back and forth too quickly so that
you remain
in control and the next level things get
a little bit more complex
because we're going to let the yoyo
leave our hand level 5
skyrocket the skyrocket begins in a
downward throw
you let the yoyo sleep at the very end
and then you let the yoyo string and the
slip knot off your hand
and throw the yoyo up in the air as the
yoyo is midway in the air
it rolls back up and as it is falling
down you catch it in your hands
so when you are learning skyrocket for
the first time it is really important
that after you let the yoyo go off your
hand and throw it up in the air
you have your eye on the prize ready to
catch it if you don't do that
unfortunately the yoyo will fall on the
floor
and you will dent your 500 titanium yoyo
now that things are getting a little bit
more complex
it's time to switch to an unresponsive
yoyo so the unresponsive yoyo
is going to be harder because you cannot
bring an unresponsive yoyo back up
you have to purposefully not the yoyo
which we will be delving into in the
next level
level six bind the bind is how you
return
an unresponsive yoyo so it is a matter
of purposefully nodding the yoyo which
contacts the friction surface on either
side
forcing the yoyo to come back up this is
the first unresponsive yoyo trick that
people learn because you need to learn
how to bring the yoyo back up
otherwise you are going to spend a lot
of time winding it back up manually
so you begin in a downward sleeper like
our first trick that we learned
but instead of tugging the yoyo back up
you rest your index finger
on the front of the yoyo string you wrap
around
you hit the yoyo and then cross the
strings and then give it a little tug to
bring it back up
when you give it a little tug you will
have a loop of string that will fall
into the gap of the yoyo
this will contact the friction surface
causing the yoyo to spin back up
so the most important thing to remember
is control and to also have a really
really good throw because if you don't
throw the yoyo hard enough it won't spin
for a long enough time at the very end
and you will not have enough time
to wrap the yoyo string around it to
bring it back up
so in unresponsive yoyoing there are
three main styles
of yoyo tricks so you have your front
style throw which is where you are
throwing the yoyo down
right in front of you you have your side
style through which is where you're
throwing
the yoyo off to the side and then
finally a horizontal
throw where the yoyo spins off axis all
the tricks that we see in past six
levels
have used a forward throw the next will
be using a side style throw
level seven trapeze so the trapeze
starts
in a breakaway throw instead of throwing
the yoyo in front of you
you make a muscle formation off to the
side you extend your arm flick your
wrist
just the same and you land on a trapeze
so the yoyo in this case is the man and
the string
is a trapeze so as the yoyo is coming
through through that breakaway
you flick the yoyo onto your index
string and it lands
in a formation or mount called the
trapeze as the yoyo is coming through
it is important that you land the yoyo
on the trapeze
when beginners are learning this trick
the yoyo will fall off and so you kill
the man on the trapeze
level eight brain twister so the brain
twister
is a super impressive trick especially
when you're starting to learn how to
yoyo and involves throwing the yoyo down
in a downward sleeper right in front of
you
and very similar to the bind where you
go in front of the yoyo
this time you will want to go behind and
so you mount the yoyo from behind and
you have one longer string statement
one shorter string segment and he pushed
the yoyo into you
you force the yoyo to rotate and you
want to do that three times very similar
to
rock the baby you let the string stay
make go and then bring the yoyo back
up so the next level things are going to
get a little bit more complex
because we're going to be in combining
two tricks that we've seen before the
trapeze and the brain twister
level nine skin the gerbil so skin the
gerbil
funny name begins in a trapeze and then
you
double mount the trapeze on so there's
two loops around your index finger on
your non throwhand
you unloop the yoyo and then you mount
the yoyo on your opposite index finger
you unmount you do a brain twister like
motion you dismount from the trapeze
and then you bring the yoyo back up for
this trick in particular control is
especially important
you want to make sure that you're
landing the yoyo on the string and
dismounting it correctly
sometimes you make fumble and the yoyo
might not land on the string correctly
and so that precision
is super important because the yoyo
trick is longer as well it is important
that you
have a really good spin at the start
otherwise the yoyo may die
or stop spinning midway through so now
we are moving on to the next level
which could be considered our first mini
combo
level 10 mach 5 so mark 5 begins
in a forward throw and you start in a
split bottom mount
you do a barrel rule and then isolate
the yoyo in the center of the string
and you rotate your index fingers around
the yoyo so it looks like the yoyo is
stationary while you're moving around it
it's very similar to you know contact
juggling where the object is staying in
one position and you're manipulating
around it after you do
three full rotations or three mach 5
revolutions
you dismount and you bring the yoyo back
up by doing a simple bind
this trick requires a lot a lot of
control
to keep the yoyo in that single space as
you are rotating around it you don't
want to rotate too quickly
but you also don't want to rotate too
slowly because you're putting so much
pressure
on the yoyo to maintain it in one space
the yoyo may spin
off axis and gyroscope the key to
maintaining that control
is by pulling your index fingers away
from the yoyo
so that it forces it to stay in that one
position and then when you're doing your
rotations you want to rotate at a
constant motion
so that the yoyo doesn't stop spinning
midway through
the next trick is going to involve a hop
element which is
unlike any other trick that we've seen
so far today
level 11 eli hop the eli hop
starts in a breakaway through you mount
the yoyo in a trapeze
and then by bringing your hands together
really quickly
the yoyo springs up and launches off to
the side
you then land the yoyo back on the
trapeze and that performs one eli hop
the eli hop is super impressive because
its so unexpected
the yoyo is stationary and a trapeze and
then suddenly it springs off to the side
and hops out and then you land it back
on the trapeze so it's very
unpredictable and there's so many
different variations of the trick too
where you can do some eli hops which are
much
larger in amplitude some which are much
smaller and you can combine various eli
hops together
to create a combo level 12 boingy boingy
like the ones that we've seen before
with the mach 5. the boogie boy
begins in a downward throw and then you
mount the yoyo and
1.5 mount you do a single barrel roll
and then you have the yoyo
between your two index fingers and you
pop the yoyo back and forth between each
string segment
causing it to boingy boing back and
forth you want to do that a handful of
times
you then dismount the yoyo and you
return it with a bind
when learning a boingy boing for the
first time it is really easy for the
yoyo to fall off the string
mid boy you are doing your boogie boing
and then the yoyo
will pop off the string and then you
have to restart so its important that
you have that control to
bounce the yoyo back and forth between
those two strings and you have a clear
eye on where the yoyo is
at every given motion so the additional
complexity that we'll be introducing in
the next trick
involves a slack element level 13
revolutions
revolutions is a repeater a repeater
that we seen before
was the mach 5 and very similarly the
eli hop or
the rock the baby were you doing a
moment repetitively but with the
revolutions you're manipulating a slack
element so you begin in a split bottom
mount
and when you're in that split bottom
mount you pinch the string with your
index finger and your thumb
causing the yoyo string to slack you
then rotate the yoyo string
inwards and outwards from your hand
causing the yoyo string to fold the yoyo
as the yoyo spins through the air
it is almost like waving a fan after you
have repeated it a handful of times
you dismount from the mount and you
bring the yoyo back up with a revolution
very similar to the mach 5 it is really
important that you maintain your
momentum as you are doing each of those
revolutions if you start spinning the
yoyo midway through
the yoyo slack formation will break and
then you will have to
repeat it again level 14 brent stole
so the brent stoll involves a new kind
of element called
the laceration so with the laceration
you pop the yoyo
up into the air and you create a slack
movement underneath the yoyo and create
a formation
so that when the yoyo falls back onto
the string it falls into that formation
or into that mount
so with the brent stoll in particular
the yoyo falls into a triangle-like
formation or triangle-like mount one of
the common mistakes
when players learn brentstall for the
first time is not
slacking the yoyo underneath the string
enough to create a large enough
loop to create that triangle formation
for the yoyo to land back onto the
string
so the next level is also repeater and
it involves the slack element
and you rotate around your non-index
throwhand
level 15 yuki slack so you begin
an f side style throw and start in
trapeze
you then pinch your index finger and
your thumb of your non throwhand
flag the string by rotating it with a
clockwise motion
and catch the string segment in a double
or nothing you then dismount from that
double or nothing off to the side
hit the yoyo on the bottom of the string
and slack the yoyo in the opposite
direction
you catch a string segment as it is
going around and then you repeat the
motion again
so you dismount you hop onto the string
on the trapeze and you slack it over
into a double or nothing
back and forth back and forth after
you're done your fair share of yuki
slacks
you dismount and you bring the yoyo back
up so one difficulty with
the uk slack is that the trick can fall
apart on successive repeats
as you're slacking the yoyo back and
forth back and forth it is really easy
for the string and the yoyo to get
tangled up
and resulting in a dead yoyo and a knot
in your hand
level 16 black ops black hops
requires a lot of precision and a lot of
control you begin in a triple or nothing
mount which is very similar to the
double or nothing but you rotate the
yoyo around the string one more time so
that there's
three string segments on either index
finger when you're in that triple or
nothing
you then bounce the yoyo off the string
consecutively until you reach a trapeze
so you're constantly bouncing the yoyo
back up
landing on the string bouncing the yoyo
back up landing it on the string
and then you land in that trapeze once
you are at the trapeze you want to build
back up to a triple or nothing
so you hop the yoyo back up slashed you
off to the side it lands
in a trapeze and his brother jump the
yoyo back up it lands
in a double or nothing and you continue
until you're in triple or nothing
once you're in that triple or nothing
again you drop all the string statements
so it's just resting on your index
finger you dismount
and you do a bind to bring the yoyo back
up so with black hops precision and
control are your best friend
you really want to make sure that you
have an eye on the yoyo as it's hopping
between those strings
and you're landing on each string
segment clearly when you're going down
to the trapeze and when you're moving
back
up very similarly you're landing on each
string segment clearly
so the next trick we're going to make
the yoyo look like it's skipping rope
level 17 follows
the trick begins in a trapeze like many
other tricks and you dismount
you then slash the yoyo with a karate
chop like motion
that creates a loop around your
throwhand
and then you rotate around the yoyo
multiple times kind of like
skipping rope after you are done
rotating around the yoyo a handful of
times
you land the yoyo in iron whip which is
where the yoyo trick originated from
and then you bring the yoyo back up
through a bind like the yuki slack
like the revolution like the mach 5 the
follows
is a repeater with this trick momentum
is super super important
after you start the trick you have to
keep following through otherwise
the yoyo and the string and the slack
will get tangled up
for the next trick we are going to be
incorporating another part of our body
and the yoyo is going to land behind our
back
level 18 leg wrap trap
so the leg wrap trap begins in a
breakaway throw you do a handful of
around the worlds
and then you step over the string with
your right leg and then shortly after
with your left leg
and then afterwards you land in a
trapeze behind your back
you quickly dismount and bring the yoyo
back up to your hand so this yoyo trick
is also commonly known as
the ball breaker because the yoyo string
is going between your legs and
can break your balls lots of mistakes
can be made with this trick
the next trick is another laceration and
involves
wrapping the yoyo string around the yoyo
enough times
so you land in a 2.5 mount level 19
2.5 hook so the 2.5 hook
like the triangle laceration involves
popping the yoyo up
and spinning the yoyo string around the
yoyo multiple times to land the yoyo
back into a mount when it falls back
down
in this case it is a 2.5 mount which is
like the one and a half mount
but with two and a half strings wrapped
around the yoyo instead
so the yoyo begins in a breakaway throw
you pop the yoyo up
as the yoyo is midway through the air
you take your two index fingers and you
are wrapping around the string multiple
times
two and a half times to be exact as the
yoyo is falling back into the you string
you land in that 2.5 mount so this trick
is really challenging because it's quite
risky
you either get it or you don't you have
to try multiple times and it can be
quite tiring to pop the yoyo back
up spin around with your index fingers
and then land back onto the string
so with this trick because you're
rotating around the yoyo multiple times
it's common to not catch the string when
it lands in the 2.5 mount
so up to this point we've looked at the
front style throw and the breakaway
throw but we'll be introducing
a new throw in this upcoming trick the
horizontal throw
level 20 banana turnover and horizontal
pinwheel
so the banana turnover and the
horizontal pinwheel are two sides of the
same coin
they're just different based off of the
way that you begin with the throw
so in the case of the banana turnover
it's more of a side style throw but
horizontal
and with the horizontal pinwheel it's
like a downward forward facing through
but horizontal
so beginning with banana turnover you
begin in a side style throw but instead
horizontal so kind of like you're
throwing a frisbee and then
as the yoyo is going around almost like
you're about to hit in the trapeze
you stick out your thumb facing
downwards of your non throwhand and the
yoyo
will wrap around your thumb causing it
to rotate you do that a couple of times
and that rebalances the plane of the
yoyo so that you can land it in a
trapeze
after you're in that trapeze you can do
a variety of different tricks
the banana turnover is a starting point
to many horizontal tricks and then you
bring it back up
with the horizontal pinwheel you're
throwing the yoyo across your body and
as the yoyo is fully extended at the end
of the string
you are doing a series of pinwheels to
keep it in the same plane very similar
to the banana turnover after that you
can transition into a horizontal combo
and then bring the yoyo up with a bind
horizontal tricks are a lot more
challenging than your typical saad style
or front style throw
because you have to keep the yoyo
spinning otherwise it will spin
out of plane level 21 ufo
the ufo is a horizontal trick and you
begin by doing a banana turnover
as the yoyo is spinning around your
thumb you let it rest for a second
almost allowing it to spin out and spin
out of control
but before it starts spinning you pop
the yoyo up
and you catch the yoyo returning it into
bind it is called the ufo
because it looks like a ufo is about to
land the yoyo
is flat when you're performing the trick
flat on the horizontal plane
and the yoyo string spirals around it
because it's about to die
you know you've done this trick
correctly because the yoyo will look
like it's hovering midway through the
air
so the ufo is all about timing it's
about timing the amount of spin left in
the yoyo before you return it but you
also want it to let it spin out for a
couple of rotations
so that you can get that cool hovering
effect in that process
the yoyo may spin out of control the
yoyo may die
in between or you may not catch the
yo-yo as you pop it up
we're at a really advanced level now and
for the next trick we're going to add a
little bit of complexity
by involving our neck level 22 the zack
gormley nectric
it involves starting in a trapeze
dismounting
bringing the yoyo string above your head
and above your neck
wrapping the string so it lands in a
chopstick with your index finger
and your thumb of your throwhand pulling
apart almost like you're doing a
revolution
extending the yoyo above and over your
head crunching down
so that the slack follows you
dismounting and bringing the yoyo back
up
so this trick involves a lot of the
levels that we seen before including the
trapeze
the revolution and the slack so with the
zagwormly electric
at one point you're not able to see the
yoyo because it's above your head
so you need to make sure that you're
extending far enough over so you don't
accidentally hit yourself so the next
trick is the last
of our non-combo tricks and involves
spinning the yoyo
on your finger level 23 finger spin
sidewinder so the finger spin sidewinder
begins a horizontal pinwheel throw after
you pinwheel a handful
of times you pop the yoyo up and land
the yoyo
on your index finger of your non
throwhand it will spin there for a
couple moments
and after the yoyo is about to die very
similar to the ufo
you lacerate into the center of the
string causing the yoyo to bind
as the yoyo is binding you hover your
throwhand
on top of the yoyo causing the yoyo to
do a sidewinder movement
causing the yoyo to return back up to
your hand it is really important that
you keep in mind the timing very similar
to the ufo when you land it on your
finger the yoyo will spin out really
quickly because of the additional amount
of friction
and additionally after you return the
yoyo back up to your hand
it will mess up the string tension so
the slack and the string will be all
over the place
so it'll be really difficult to do
subsequent tricks if you decide to do a
finger spin
and sidewinder during the middle of a
routine so the next couple of tricks are
combinations that i've created myself
level 24 the eli hop combo
so in a competition yours will often
perform an eli hop combo
so an eli hog combo involves the trick
that we saw before
the eli hop it's a matter of doing
different variations of that same trick
in different directions
in different sizes in different planes
so my take on the eli hop
combo begins in a reverse rent stool
i pop the yoyo off to the side my right
hand side
i then pop it in the opposite direction
to the left hand side of my body
i then do a series of pop elements and
land the yoyo in a reverse
hook i then do reverse
behind the elbow double or nothing i
dismount
very similar to a black hop i land the
yoyo string
inverted in an inverted trapeze and then
i return the yoyo back to my hand
so this eli hop combo is something that
i've been working on from 2017
and i've been continuously adding new
elements and new tricks as i've learned
them
level 25 neck behind the back leg combo
so the neck behind the back leg combo
involves three body parts your neck your
leg of course
and then doing tricks behind your back
so you start in a yuki slack like
movement
and as a result you go around your neck
wrapping around your neck
and when you unravel you unravel so the
yoyo is landing behind your back
when the yoyo is behind your back you do
a pop-like motion returning the yoyo
back to a trapeze in front of your body
invert the yoyo string and you go
underneath
your non-throwhand leg so it catches
underneath
after you catch the yoyo string
underneath your leg so that
the yoyo is hanging underneath your leg
you do a series of pop movements
and then eventually pop the yoyo back
out back to a trapeze
you do a series of like elements and
then land in an amount
to return the yoyo back to your hand so
a lot of things can go wrong with this
trick
simply because of the number of
different body parts involved
the number of different elements and the
number of transitions that you have to
make between
each of those main components so behind
the back around the neck and around the
leg
when you're trying to unravel the yoyo
string around the neck so that it lands
behind your back
it will unravel in the wrong direction
causing you
to have a yo-yo just wrapped around your
body ultimately the possibility for
combinations
are endless all those tricks that you've
seen all those levels
can be combined in various different
ways to create
various combos in a competition players
will take their own tricks take their
own combos
and create a freestyle routine freestyle
yo-yoing is arguably the most difficult
because it combines various elements
tricks and combinations
into a single routine level 26 freestyle
freestyling is when you just let the
yoyo do its thing
you do the first trick that comes to
your mind and then from that trick
you transition into the next trick
really wherever your hands take you
freestyling is about making decisions in
the moment it's
more of an intuition thing where you're
just transitioning between elements
transitioning between mounts
so that you're creating various combos
as you go it's a matter of then
taking those tricks matching those
tricks to music playing around with the
pacing playing around with you know body
elements playing around with tricks
which are smaller and technical and
really going with the song
and the moment sometimes those decisions
may lead to a knot
sometimes those decisions may lead to a
fantastic trick
it's really about messing around seeing
you at work seeing what doesn't
and that's one of the fun parts about
yoyoing because there's so many
limitless possibilities
thanks wired